Michael Jordan's 1984 Olympic converse
shoes signed by Jordan have already set
a new world record price what was the
price that it surpassed what is this for
shoes poly or for auction items ox not
above Jordan shoes I think another one
of his pairs of shoes went for 140 150
how much did these shoes go for was this
144 thousand dollars for these shoes
from the Olympics take one hundred and
seventy one for one hundred and seventy
thousand dollars for Jordans game used
Olympic converse that's pretty high-end
sports memorabilia not a lot of no one
else is going to have one on your block
hmm thank
let's bring in Chris Weber joins us now
do you have any interesting memorabilia
Chris do I have any interested
memorabilia I do after Duke beat asthma
championship I've been grant fans of
Grant Hill since 1814 and my little
brother David he walks up to my little
brother who was with his birthday around
that time gave New Jersey and a short so
in my office
obviously I took it from a little
brother but it's a home I have a grant
as granules college outfit when they
beat us in the game to do that uniform
and then one of my other favorite pieces
I have remember the 50 greatest when
they were named back it was here in
Cleveland I forgot what year it was I
was lucky enough in all-star team so I
bought a plane where all of their
signature so everyone in the top 50
besides I think a Pistol Pete I have
their picture in their autograph on a
limited edition with all that show I
mean I know that's a lot of money with
the Jordans but you think about if you
have Wilkes um
converse or someone else's I'm sure
that's a great investment because it's
only going to go up at the time so yeah
those are those are probably two of my
favorite uh memorabilia pieces that I
have how long we look like long with my
varsity jacket from college and my
uniform stuff like that but others
that's what that's why I'm here how long
were you in the league before you
started asking for autographed jerseys
of players you're competing against well
my first day
I had to have a productive I came out to
Golden State late the first day I met
Chris Mullin I got an autograph and I
went to his house and spent the night
and so yeah the day one before I got I
was asked and I had no no no shame about
that if you were favorite player of mine
Isiah someone else you know I'd go up
and ask you for some memory doing that I
will say this too when I got traded
joked about this before I think when
Kobe was getting Lacombe he was retiring
that I couldn't believe none of the
young players had like raided his locker
and so when AI was traded and I was in
Philly and he got traded to Denver
you know he was traded like on the
contentious circumstances so you know
you don't want to go to locker room and
get your stuff so I got up literally
5:44 a eyshan 20 practice journey I mean
I got jockstrap socks
I just thought ball boys look going
there give me everything and yes I'm hot
I do like a billion he's Chris Weber you
can see Chris NBA TV's comprehensive
studio coverage NBA Finals I'm enjoying
that though the demonstrations you guys
have on the floor you with Charles and
Shaq there and Matt Winer it's it's been
a lot of fun to have you guys dissect
the finals but let me ask you this
question no Chris are the Warriors good
for basketball or bad for basketball man
that's a tough question okay I think
they're great for basketball and I'll
tell you why because of the style that
they're playing now if you had three
superstars like they have and they're
going one-on-one and it's ISO ball and
it's just you know boring it'd be
terrible but these guys are playing the
right way I think when the Brian came in
we remember Easter question did he make
the right play the right pass and I've
always looked at the broad like Magic
Johnson with Jordans athletic ability
and with Kobe
Jordan other guys before then it was how
much you can score it was you know Chris
take a bad shot don't pass the page in
the corner you gotta score assists you
don't play the right way and now with I
think LeBron and Golden State we're
seeing them play the right way back cuts
keeping guys keeping the office out is
keeping the integrity of the pieces I
mean they're the best defensive team in
the league and so I think how
the highlight and how fun it is to watch
them almost takes away from their
substance because they really play
defense it's just they can come down and
shoot a 54 3 and make it but we don't
look at the steel they got to shoot that
3 but I think it's good for basketball
because kids now even if you're shooting
like step-step-step hurry
even if you're dribbling like you got to
find your man klay Thompson you gotta
find your Bell McGee and make him better
so I think is good for basketball
because these guys are playing the right
way what are the cams missing Talent Wow
and I mean you know when you look at it
you just they played eight guys the
other day go don't stay can play the
whole roster I'm not using about
strategy then there's nothing tyronn lue
can do differently that's going to
change would have changed this outcome
now I got hurt in there the time we came
out coach that's I don't believe that at
all I just think that he cannot LeBron
for a long period of time and if Kyrie
doesn't at least have 30 they don't have
a chance
um it's I picked the Cavs in six before
the season started and I thought it
would take one year for Durant to get to
know each other because that's been
about the time they've taken whether the
Shaq going somewhere LeBron going
somewhere it took about a year you know
you're getting that first year free
interest how does the best team that
they don't 173 last games last year how
they go out and get just such a great
player who was improving this game so
it's it's just for this funk me to watch
right now Durant because he's so
efficient and he's better because of the
system it's so tough to score one-on-one
always have to do it but you can get the
same amount of points and and kind of
relieve pressure in other ways getting
other guys involved in the system so I
know he's having fun doing it but this
is just extraordinary I don't know what
more the TAS can do with disappointing
the Tristan Thompson Anthony getting a
bunch of rebounds of disappointment Kyle
who I played with he was my rookie I'm
telling you I've never seen a guy shoot
as many threes and of course Mullen and
Paige I put them in that so missing that
shot but hey they're just missing guys
that can go hit their own bucket like
like Golden State they're just they're
just a better team do you think the
Warriors would have gone after Kevin
Durant if they won the NBA title last
year
that's a great question and I'm gonna
say yes really I think I asked I think I
was talking with Chuck about this is one
of the best parts about my job like it's
a [ __ ] and toggle guys like you and
argue all day and talk about the games
but I really hire I say this that I want
distance Casal there but they needed
more I think their team their their
their gym their staff they need it more
if you look at this I believe that with
the same team that have lashes they
would not have a chance in this final
I'm coming down 3-1 you bring it back
the same team the Brawn and these guys
are are better and and focused in and
they know it Durant is the difference
let's let's be clear it's not the
coaches it's not it's not anything else
I'll give them the system and Durant and
so I think that they klay Thompson
really stepped up really stepped up but
I don't know if he could have been that
number 2 guy and and then have won it
this year I just I don't know probably
but I'm not I wouldn't bet on it
can you remember an athlete whether it's
basketball or not another sport who has
been scrutinized as much as LeBron James
has been no and then I would I would ask
you this I you know this might a.m. on
yours
I've never seen an athlete overcome or
meet the standards that were set before
he was paid a hundred million before he
even stepped in India I mean people were
saying this guy could be one of the
greatest so even before you saw him you
already was like come on he can't beat
the expectation and I just think it's
incredible the pressure that he had
coming in and he's met every expectation
or surpassed our expectations now I've
never I've never seen an athlete like
him and I talked about friends that
played football baseball and a lot of
them say the same thing
do you ever remind Barkley of that play
you had a golden state where you went
behind your back on a fast break and you
dunked on Charles no that's not you know
I keep in the back in my back pocket you
know just because you know we start
talking jump all day but not really
because then I did that I feel so good
it was great and then he hit us with
City for the playoffs with this so I've
always kind of you know I love looking
at the old commercials and things like
that but
I never thought I was such a big fan of
Barbie man growing up with him Dominique
bird magic I had on my wallet you know a
lot of times it's funny I was doing a
fight with the other day I really have
to check myself a lot of times and just
say wow this is so surreal um you know I
know that my peers and contemporaries I
get that but thinking back from a place
where you know well I used to dream
about this and so now it's pretty cool
but I never I never really bring that up
you know
nah I don't how are the kids they're
doing great crying and lungs on the
diapers are being filled every two hours
so inside the work in the laundry worker
so it's cloud9 knows the best in the
world
you doing great it's a lot of fun I love
watching the pre and post with you guys
tell the guys should be settle oh and
thanks again for talking
hey thanks hopefully one day I come in
high school get some get some swings on
your hundred golf on your golfing I see
how he plans to maybe one day I get a
game which but uh thanks for having a
lot always well being on the show are we
going to shoot free throws if you come
in here see I don't even say that
because you're a great free-throw
shooter yeah but I got to find something
you're not fake you're not that good at
we can go as two but you have issue free
drugs in that and I'll play maybe play
one of those famous courses there or no
okay all right you come in
we'll play Pebble Beach okay sound I've
never played before so it sounds good
all right thank you Chris I thank
yourself see web NBA on TNT pregame
shows great because you think Shaq and
Charles are unfiltered on TNT when
they're on the NBA TV they're even
looser and it's a lot of fun the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience